[Music]
today we're finally going to answer the
question of how do we combine firebase
with angular Universal to build a search
engine optimized JavaScript app recent
changes to angular fire to now make it
possible to perform server-side
rendering with Universal what this means
is that our apps content can be
understood by search engines and used by
social media link BOTS and we might even
get some good page load performance
gains out of it if you're new here make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and I highly
recommend that you follow along with the
source code on angular firebase comm
first let's talk about what server-side
rendering is normally we just let the
browser parcel of the JavaScript and
render it out to HTML but this becomes a
problem if your app has routes that need
to be indexed in a search engine or
shared on social media most bots that
visit your site only understand HTML and
don't make any effort to parse the
JavaScript that's there what we can do
is make our angular app behave more like
a traditional web application that
responds with HTML from a server on the
first page visit it will render the app
to HTML and then send it over to the
browser which will then take over and
transition it to work just like a
regular angular app in this demo I'll
show you how to go from 0 to deployed
angular Universal app and will generate
all the content with this collection of
animals that I have stored in the
firestore database I should warn you
that we have a lot of code to get
through but most of its configuration
related stuff that you can just copy and
paste into your project but I documented
everything step-by-step in the main
article so you can follow along with
that if you get lost step one is to
generate a new angular app and make sure
that it has a routing module then
install the latest version of angular
fire 2 and firebase and then send a
thank-you card to James from firebase
because he made some pretty epic changes
to this library to make Universal
support possible after that's done
install a platform server from angular
and if you're doing lazy loading you'll
also need this NG Universal module map
NG factory loader and TS loader as well
when it comes to social media bots
they're going to be looking for meta
tags in the head of the document you can
find the specific requirements on the
Facebook and Twitter developer Docs but
what I want to show you first is how to
efficiently set these meta tags within
angular service
let's call this our SEO service and
we'll add it to the app module angular's
browser platform has a couple helpers to
set meta tags as well as the document
title so we'll import those and then
inject them in the constructor then I'm
going to define a method that will take
an object as its argument different
social media sites have different
requirements for meta tags which are
often very similar so to keep our code
dry we're going to set some defaults and
then just override these defaults with
whatever we pass in this tags object
which will ultimately be data that we
pull from firestore first we can use the
title service to set the document title
and then we'll set our meta tags as far
as I know we have to call update tag on
each one of these because there's no way
an angular to update them all in bulk
now that that's done we need a component
that gets loaded by the router and use
it to set these meta tags let's go ahead
and call this our animal detail
component then we'll use this component
in our router and we'll make sure to set
up a route params for the name which
should match the document ID that we
have saved in firebase for a given
animal the next step is to go into the
component and we'll need a variety of
things here including our SEO service as
well as the firestore database then
we'll use activated route to get the
current animal name from the URL that
that user navigated to again that is the
document ID and firestore and we can get
it by calling route snapshot brand map
followed by get name if we look at this
data in fire store quickly you'll see we
have a variety of documents with an idea
of bird cat elephant etc then each of
these documents has a bio as well as an
image URL and a name what we need to do
is read this document and then once we
have the document data use it to set the
meta tags on the dom angularfire to
gives us the data as an observable so we
can pipe in the tap operator then once
we have the data we can use our SEO
service to generate the tags but this
does bring up one problem because we're
going to read this document on the
server and then transition back to the
browser it will read the document twice
and the user will see a brief flash in
between those requests this is slowed
down significantly but notice how we get
some initial data from the server it
goes
blank then it comes back online after
we've transitioned into the browser
fortunately Universal gives us some
tools to transition state from the
server side to the client side it just
allows you to set a key value pair on
the server and then read it on the
browser so we'll import transfer State
as well as make state key then we'll set
up a constant here with make state key
and give it the name of animal when we
get data on the server we'll set it as
this animal key and then read it when we
get back to the browser and transfer
State is a service so we'll add that to
our constructor and then I'm going to
define this as its own isolated method
so you can reuse it if you have use for
this in your own app so what we're going
to do in this method is first check if a
document already exists this should
always return false on the server it
takes that key we defined as the first
argument and then a default value as the
second argument and just like we did
before we'll get our fire stored
document as an observable and pipe in
the tap operator but this time we will
set the animal key with the document
data and we can also set our meta tag
values here like we did before so the
only question that remains is how do we
use this existing document for our
observable value once we transition to
the browser and the answer is super easy
we have an rxjs operator called start
with and we can just pass at that
existing object so instead of null you
still have your existing document from
the server but it is worth noting that
this will execute to document reads and
firestore so that may or may not be an
issue for you keep in mind that you only
server-side render on a full page load
so it's unlikely that that would be an
issue in most cases the last thing we
need to do is go into the animal detail
component and subscribe to the animal
observable which we can do with the
async pipe that takes care of our front
end angular app portion now we have a
whole bunch of configuration stuff to do
with angular Universal most of the stuff
is copy and paste configuration for
right now but hopefully some of this
comes to the angular CLI in the future
first we'll go into the existing app
module and add with server transition to
the browser module import and set any
random app ID that you want and then
make sure to in
the transfer state module if you're
doing a state transfer as well then the
next thing you'll need to do is create
an app server module and it should also
live inside the app directory basically
all this is doing is taking your app
module and then importing it into
another module that is set up to be
rendered on the server then if you're
transferring state you'll need the
server transfer state module and also
the module map loader if you're doing
lazy loading in your app you wouldn't
want lazy loading on the server so that
module takes care of that aspect for you
that should take care of everything in
the app directory now we're going to
move up to the source directory and add
a new file called main server TS all it
has to do is import the app server
module that we just created this is more
of a formality because main is our main
entry point into the app we also need to
create a TS config for our main server
TS file so create TS config dot server
JSON one of the main differences between
the browser build and the server build
is that our server build needs to be in
common j/s so it can work on nodejs
the next thing we need to do is
configure our app with the angular CLI
so the CLI knows how to bundle it and
where to transpile all the code the next
thing we'll do is build our actual
server code which uses Express j/s which
is one of the most popular HTTP
frameworks for node.js create the server
TS file and then copy and paste all of
this Express j/s code into that file
this code was taken from the official
angular universal demo and only a few
little modifications were made here and
there to make it work with firebase for
example firebase uses a few things that
aren't available in nodejs such as
WebSockets but a way to get around this
is to set them on the global object
which is the equivalent to the window
object in a browser there's a handful of
things you might need in your project to
make the server environment compatible
with firebase I was able to install them
with this command which you can find in
the main article if you look at the
Express j/s app you'll notice that it's
not the prettiest code ever the most
important thing to understand here is
that this Express app is capturing all
of the routes
our angular application and then
rendering them to HTML based on wherever
the user navigates so that means they
can navigate to a deep link and they'll
get the rendered HTML for that page the
one thing about Express is that it's
completely separate from our angular
application the angular CLI has no way
to compile this down to a production
build for us and we can roll out our own
web pack config to do that create
another file called web pack server dot
config dot jas and we're gonna add some
more not-so-pretty code to it but
essentially what we're doing is what the
angular CLI does under the hood in this
case it's taking our typescript file and
compiling it down to JavaScript that can
run on node you should be able to copy
and paste this and just forget about it
as long as you're placing all of your
files in the same place that we did in
this lesson we're getting really close
to the end here the next thing we need
to do is go up into the root of the
project and in the angular CLI JSON file
and a configuration for our server app
you'll notice that the apps option is an
array that's because we can add multiple
apps to the angular CLI configuration
which is exactly what we need to do here
again we're doing another copy and paste
style thing where we take the existing
app and then we make a few modifications
to it to point to the resources for our
server app we will appoint the main
entry point to the main server TS file
we can also remove polyfills because
they're not needed on the server and you
want to set serviceworker to false if
using a worker at this point we need to
build three different apps our Express J
a server or angular browser app and
angular server app we can do this in the
package.json in the scripts object
basically we're just combining our ng
build commands with our web pack config
to run everything all at once we can run
these two commands together by doing an
NPM run build : s SR and serve : s SR
when the build finishes it should serve
your express app on localhost 4000 and
you should see all three apps in the
dist folder but it really shouldn't feel
any different than a normal angular app
it just has the secret power to be
understood
by link BOTS and search engines if you
copy a link from your app and paste it
into the Twitter cart validator you
should see a valid card even though this
data is pulled from the firestore
database asynchronously and you'll also
want to check to see if you've achieved
any performance games from SSR for this
demo I ran a lighthouse on it and
achieve a score of 94 which is really
good for an angular app pulling data
from firebase I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want to talk about more advanced
SSR scenarios consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get access to all kinds of exclusive
content designed to help you ship apps
on the angular firebase stack thanks for
watching and I'll see you soon